nach dem Tod der jungen Kurden Gina Masa
Amini im September 2022 rollt eine
Protestwelle durch die Islamische
Republik
große Proteste gab es in Iran schon sehr
oft doch diesmal sagen viele sei es
anders diesmal sei es eine Revolution
viel ist seit damals in Iran passiert
Proteste Hinrichtungen mysteriöse
Giftanschläge wo steht die
Protestbewegung heute die Bewegung deren
Motte um die Welt ging
jangi Frau Leben Freiheit
[Musik]
unser zdf-büro liegt im Norden herans im
zehnten Stock eines Geschäftshauses
ich bin Korrespondent für die Türkei und
Iran pendelle zwischen Istanbul und
Teheran
mein Team besteht aus vier Leuten alle
iranische Staatsbürger die Kameramänner
Salman Ibrahimi und Mahmut galbi
Producerin absahne aus dovar und Kata
Beran sanjabi
wie alle die für ausländische Medien in
Iran arbeiten müssen wir uns bei
Ministerium für Kultur und islamische
Führung akkreditieren um unsere
pressekarten zu bekommen
das Ministerium erteilt dreh- und Reise
Genehmigung alle Berichte die wir im
Land produzieren werden genau beobachtet
jeder Dreh jede Geschichte kann für mein
Team zum Problem werden muss deshalb
genau geplant sein
[Musik]
und das gilt erst recht für Geschichten
wie die Übermaße Amini und den
Volksaufstand gegen das Regime der mit
der Rebellion der Frauen begann
die moralpolizei kommt in Kleinbussen
nimmt Frauen mit die das Kopftuch nicht
ordentlich tragen
die Sittenwächter sind verhasst es
drohen Prügel Stunden auf der
Polizeiwache während eines solchen
Aufenthalts bei der moralpolizei fällt
Gina Maße armini ins Koma
terranspolizeischef bestreitet das ist
zu Gewalt gekommen ist
der zustand ihres Kopftuchs war nicht
vorschriftsgemäß deshalb wurde sie in
einen Polizeifahrzeug gebeten weder sie
noch eine der anderen Frauen haben
Widerstand geleistet sondern haben mit
uns kooperiert
[Musik]
Irans Staatsfernsehen veröffentlicht
Bilder von aminis Aufenthalt in der
Polizei Station
[Musik]
es zeigt den Saal in dem die
Festgenommenen von einer Beamten im
Tschador belehrt werden sollen Amini
betritt den Raum bricht kurz darauf
zusammen ohne Fremdeinwirkung doch was
passierte zwischen ihrer Festnahme und
diesen Bildern Bilder den viele im Land
nicht trauen
im Staatsfernsehen heißt es sie sei
zusammengebrochen und der Grund sei eine
Vorerkrankung des Gehirns aber das
glauben wir nicht sie müssen ihr
Verhalten gegenüber Frauen ändern
[Musik]
drei Tage nach ihrer Festnahme wird Gina
Massa Amini am 16 September für toter
erklärt vor dem Krankenhaus versammelt
sich eine wütende Menge
Sicherheitskräfte regeln das Gelände ab
am nächsten Tag wird ihr Leichnam in
ihrer Heimatstadt sakes überführt
arminis Tod ist der Tropfen der ein Fass
voller Wut über staatliche Lügen und
Gewalt zum Überlaufen bringt die Frauen
rufen Tod den Diktator
zwei Tage nach arminis Beisetzung fährt
unser Team in die Teheraner Innenstadt
es sind Proteste angekündigt die ersten
Frauen versammeln sich
[Musik]
wir werden den töten der unsere
Schwester getötet hat rufen Sie sofort
fahren Sicherheitskräfte auf ein
Polizist entdeckt unseren Kameramann
Mahmut Galli
Minuten später wird er festgenommen
verschwindet in einem Polizeifahrzeug er
kommt kurz darauf wieder frei doch seine
Pressekarte wurde eingezogen das
bedeutet Arbeitsverbot
die Situation ist seltsam es ist nicht
leicht zu arbeiten wir erfahren viele
Einschränkungen es ist kaum noch möglich
auf der Straße zu drehen und einfache
Umfragen zu machen viele Leute wollen
nicht mit uns reden sie haben Angst
selbst Experten viele Weisen uns zurück
und lehnen Interviews ab seit dem Tod
Masse aminis werden unsere
Arbeitsbedingungen immer schwerer
[Musik]
jeden Tag gibt es nun Straßenproteste
und Zusammenstöße mit der Polizei auch
ganz in der Nähe unseres Studios doch
die Behörden verbieten dass wir uns den
Protesten nähern und mit Demonstranten
reden andernfalls drohen Strafen
trotzdem testen wir immer wieder wie
weit wir gehen können im Oktober gelingt
es uns schließlich mit einer jungen Frau
ein verdecktes Interview zu drehen sie
ist Studentin war von Anfang an mit
dabei
wenn es uns nicht gelingt dass es einen
Wandel muss ich Angst haben mich nur auf
der Straße zu zeigen aber weil ich ein
Mensch bin versuche ich die Angst zu
vergessen um ein Ziel zu erreichen aber
wenn wir es nicht schaffen wird jedes
einzelne Mitglied meiner Familie in
Gefahr sein Familie
ich sehe auf den Straßen dass die Zahl
der Sicherheitskräfte immer weiter
zunimmt
mit meinen eigenen Augen wie Sie
einfache Leute rekrutieren sie zahlen
Ihnen viel Geld pro Tag damit sie sich
ihnen anschließen und helfen das Volk zu
unterdrücken Leute die dringend Geld
brauchen schließen sich ihnen an ihre
Zahl wird weiter steigen
auf der anderen Seite steigt aber auch
die Zahl der Menschen die sich den
Protesten anschließen
unsere Stimmen werden in der ganzen Welt
gehört so etwas hat es noch nie gegeben
dass die Stimmen der einfachen Leute
gehört werden
was vielleicht erst in zehn Jahren hätte
geschehen sollen wird jetzt viel früher
passieren wir werden unser Ziel
erreichen
auch Frauen die den chador aus
religiöser Überzeugung
tragenie solidarisieren sich mit den
Protesten wir treffen die Tochter des
früheren Präsidenten
ihr Vater gehörte dem reformerlager an
auch weil sehr Chemie war immer
politisch aktiv saß als Abgeordnete im
Parlament
sie kämpft für die Rechte der Frauen
lehnt den Kopftuchzwang ab an einen
Regimewechsel aber glaubt sie nicht
ein Ergebnis der Proteste ist denke ich
dass viele Mädchen und Frauen ihre
Kopftücher abgelegt haben das ist sehr
gut ich glaube zwar nicht dass es zu
einem Regimewechsel kommen wird das wird
nicht passieren aber es könnte positive
Effekte haben
der Kopftuchzwang ist nicht akzeptabel
selbst Umfragen der Regierung zeigen
dass über 70% des Volkes die Pflicht ein
Kopftuch zu tragen ablehnen und über die
Hälfte lehnt das Kopftuch komplett ab
das ist das Ergebnis unserer Politik
wenn wir Religion fördern wollen müssen
wir einsehen dass unsere Strategie
gescheitert ist doch das Ziel der
Regierung sind weder der Hijab noch
Religion das Ziel ist allein der macht
er halt
völlig zu Unrecht glauben sie dass wenn
sie in der Frage des Kopftuchs nachgeben
die Leute weitere Forderungen stellen
und ihre Macht gefährdet ist
das Regime duldet Stimmen wie die
Feuerwehr
nach unserem Interview wird die
Oppositionspolitikerin festgenommen wird
später zu fünf Jahren Haft verurteilt
nur wenige Regierungskritiker dürfen mit
uns reden einer ist der
Politikwissenschaftler sadeh siba calam
ganz ohne Risiko ist das für ihn nicht
die Behörden verbieten ihm Interviews
mit Sender der auslands-opposition mit
dem ZDF darf er noch reden
die Regierung könnte sagen lasst doch
ein paar Frauen auf der Straße ohne
Kopftuch rumlaufen und macht deswegen
kein großes Tara etwas völlig anderes
aber wäre es wie einige fordern ein
Referendum über die hitzerpflicht
abzuhalten
das wäre politischer Selbstmord für das
islamische Regime denn sie wissen dass
mehr als 80 Prozent der Bevölkerung
gegen sie sind
das Potenzial für eine Revolution aber
das ganze hat keine Organisation
es gibt keine Führungsstruktur kein
Konzept keinen Plan
anders als bei der islamischen
Revolution 1979
eine starke Führungsfigur und um ihn
hatten sich viele Menschen versammelt
sie werden noch mehr Leute festnehmen
sie werden noch mehr Leute erschießen
weil sie hoffen dass die Leute langsam
müde werden und die Proteste dann
langsam aufhören
sagt dass es Streit in der Staatsführung
gäbe über den Umgang mit den Protesten
in diesem Streit setzen sich offenbar
die Hardliner durch
[Musik]
seit der islamischen Revolution im Jahr
1979 sieht sich das Regime im ständigen
Kampf gegen Feinde von außen und immer
wieder auch gegen das eigene Volk über
500 Tote soll es während der jüngsten
Protestwelle gegeben haben
Irans Justizapparat ist fest in der
handreligiöser Hardliner sein Chef ist
der verlängerte Arm des obersten Führers
Eier toller hammelei in kurzer Zeit
werden über 20 Todesurteile verhängt
ich werde mein bestes geben um diese
Mörder und Aufständischen zu bestrafen
die Regierung blockiert das Internet
will verhindern dass sich die Opposition
organisiert das erschwert auch unsere
Berichterstattung
fünf Wochen sind mittlerweile seit
Beginn der Proteste vergangen viele
Frauen zeigen sich in der Öffentlichkeit
ohne Kopftuch das wollen wir zeigen
so entsteht Ende Oktober dieser Bericht
aus Teheran ja
von Tag zu Tag werden es mehr Frauen
ohne Kopftuch in den Straßen Teherans
als wir eine von ihnen interviewen
wollen erkennt eine andere unser ZDF
Mikrofon und ruft auf deutsch
iranische Frauen wütend und mutig wir
wollen das Gespräch fortsetzen doch
sofort hält ein Motorrad
Sicherheitskräfte beenden unser Internet
[Musik]
am nächsten Tag meldet sich das
Ministerium unsere Producerin bekommt
Arbeitsverbot mehrere Wochen lang bis
Mitte November kann das Team kaum noch
eigene Bilder drehen
[Musik]
dann am 8 Dezember die Meldung die alle
schockiert mit dem 22-Jährigen mochten
schickeri wurde am Morgen der erste
demonstrand hin gerichtet nur wenige
Tage später wird Maggi dresa rachnerwart
öffentlicher hängt die tödliche Rache
des Regimes verfehlt ihre Wirkung nicht
aus Angst sprechen Menschen nur noch
ohne Kamera mit uns
sie haben die beiden hingerichtet um
Angst und Schrecken zu verbreiten sie
wollen keine Reformen sie wollen nicht
mit dem Volk auskommen sie wollen keinen
Schritt zurückweichen sondern versuchen
die Menschen einzuschüchtern und wollen
dass wir um unser Leben fürchten sie
wollen dass die Leute wieder Ruhe geben
so wie sie es bisher immer getan haben
[Musik]
der Plan geht auf die Zahl der
Straßenproteste geht zurück Graffitis
Tod dem Diktator rufe hubkonzerte es
sind vereinzelte Aktionen zivilen
Ungehorsams
[Musik]
die Demonstrationen werden kleiner ab
Ende Dezember hat die Protestbewegung im
Land dann Schwung verloren es herrscht
gespenstische Ruhe
einige Oppositionelle verlassen den Iran
weil sie für die Türkei kein Visum
brauchen kommen viele zuerst nach
Istanbul dort treffen wir eine junge
Frau aus Teheran sie will nicht erkannt
werden
war das erste Mal dass ich bei einer
Demo dabei war meine Beine haben vor
Angst gezittert wir waren auf dem Platz
und sie haben Tränengas in die Mitte
gefeuert alle Leute liefen auseinander
und ich habe die Schreie gehört
Harmonie ich sah eine Frau mit einem
kleinen Baby ist war vielleicht zwei
drei Monate alt die Frau kam auf mich
zugerannt Ihr Baby schrie wie am Spieß
die Frau hat mich angefleht ich solle
ihrem Kind den Rauch meiner Zigarette
ins Gesicht blasen seine Augen und die
Lungen würden vom Tränen Gas Brennen der
Rauch würde helfen meinte sie ich war
völlig geflasht
ich sollte diesen kleinen Baby den Rauch
meiner Zigarette ins Gesicht blasen
das war der Moment an dem ich sagte ich
kann das nicht mehr ich habe meinen
Freunden gesagt kommt lasst uns nach
Hause gehen
ein anderer der schon bei früheren
Protesten an forderster Front dabei war
hat sich ebenfalls in die Türkei
abgesetzt auch ihn treffen wir in
Istanbul er nennt sich Saman bezeichnet
sich selbst als Freiheitskämpfer dafür
habe ich mein linkes Auge geopfert sagt
er es sei Anfang Oktober passiert ein
Sicherheitsbeamter schoss aus kurzer
Distanz das Gummigeschoss traf ihn ins
Gesicht
schon eine Stunde nach dem Vorfall habe
ich ein Video auf Instagram gepostet das
sollte zeigen dass ich nichts bedauere
dass ich keine Angst vor ihnen habe und
das ist mir nicht leid tut
im Krankenhaus haben zwei uniformierte
Polizisten nach mir gesucht zum Glück
war ich gerade nicht im Zimmer Freunde
haben mir geholfen schnell aus dem
Krankenhaus abzuhauen ich habe dann auch
gleich das Land verlassen ich wusste sie
würden mich festnehmen und
wahrscheinlich auch hinrichten
für die Freiheit hat er sich auf seinen
Arm tätowieren lassen doch frei ist er
auch hier nicht auch in der Türkei ist
Zaman auf der Flucht wechselt ständig
den Aufenthaltsort aus Angst vor den
Herrschern des iranischen Regimes
seit der iranischen Revolution haben
10.000 Regime-Gegner das Land verlassen
hoffen auf den Sturz des Müller Regimes
doch ihr Einfluss ist begrenzt
in Berlin versammelt sich Ende Oktober
über 80.000 Menschen folgen dem Aufruf
der iranischen auslands-opposition
Großdemonstrationen auch in den USA in
Brüssel und anderen europäischen
Hauptstädten
auch in Istanbul wird demonstriert trotz
verboten der Behörden
in einem kleinen Theater in der
Istanbuler Altstadt bereitet sich Bacher
raxalechnia auf ihren Auftritt vor
Frauen tragt heißt ihr Stück es handelt
von Gewalt gegen Frauen in der Türkei
aber auch in ihrer Heimat Iran sie
spielt eine Demonstrantin die durch eine
polizei-kugel starb während der Proteste
in Iran vor 14 Jahren plötzlich war die
Geschichte wieder sehr aktuell
zwei Wochen nachdem ich das Drehbuch
geschrieben hatte starb in Iran Masse
Amini und da beschloss ich dass wir mit
unserem Theaterstück dem ganzen
iranischen Volk eine Stimme geben wollen
Freunde aus Iran schickt mir ihre
Berichte und sagten wir können nicht
selbst davon erzählen deshalb sende du
unsere Stimmen in die Welt
es passieren gerade so viele Sachen in
Iran und keiner er fährt davon
vieles bleibt unentdeckt denn es gibt
keine Bilder das tut so weh wir hören so
viele schlimme Dinge aber wir können
nichts tun leider bleibt uns nur ihre
Geschichten in den sozialen Medien zu
erzählen
[Musik]
seit sieben Jahren lebt bacharak als
Flüchtling in der Türkei wie die meisten
anderen schauspielerkolleginnen auch es
ist das Dilemma der Opposition im Exil
ihr Herz schlägt in der Heimat doch sie
sind weit weg können kaum Einfluss
nehmen auf die Ereignisse jenseits der
Grenze
manchmal will ich in den Iran
zurückgehen dann warnen mich Freunde und
sagen die werden euch gleich am
Flughafen festnehmen und ins Gefängnis
werfen also bleibe ich und fühle mich
deswegen schuldig
im Publikum sitzt ein anderer
Schauspieler Kollege kW achangar er war
in der Opposition in Iran aktiv im
drohte einer Ausreise Sperre Gefängnis
vielleicht auch er floh in die Türkei
doch der iranische Geheimdienst so
behauptet er verfolge ihn auch hier
zwei Leute überfielen mich in meiner
Wohnung Banden mir die Hände auf den
Rücken bedrohten mich mit einem Messer
und versuchten mich zu entführen aber
mit Hilfe meiner Nachbarn und eines
Freundes gelang es ihnen nicht mich
mitzunehmen
seitdem sagt er wechsle er ständig die
Wohnung während des Interviews filmt uns
eine Frau sie sei Touristin behauptet
sie als wir sie ansprechen und
verschwindet das kenne er sagt kW das
Regime übt Druck auf seine Gegner im
Ausland aus und auf deren Familien in
Iran
Großdemo in Paris auch hier ist die
Exil-Opposition aktiv das Regime
mentheeran versucht diese Opposition zum
Schweigen zu bringen und benutzt dafür
die Familien in Iran als Druckmittel
so wie im Fall von massi-ka Marie vor
vier Jahren kam sie als politischer
Flüchtling nach Frankreich engagiert
sich in einer iranischen Demokratie
Bewegung Ende Dezember klingelt bei
ihren Eltern in Teheran das Telefon am
anderen Ende ein Mitarbeiter des
iranischen Geheimdienstes er bestellt
die Eltern ein
wenn ihr heute nicht vorbeikommt werden
wir euch festnehmen sie hatten keine
Wahl jeder kennt die Adresse des
Geheimdienst Hauptquartiers in Teheran
ein berüchtigter Ort dort haben Sie das
Mobiltelefon meiner Mutter konfisziert
und dann gaben sie mir ein Ultimatum ich
müsste mich am selben Abend bei Ihnen
melden
weil der Druck auf meine Eltern so groß
geworden war habe ich schließlich die
Nummer meiner Mutter angerufen
dieses Gespräch hat sie aufgezeichnet
sie entscheidet sich damit an die
Öffentlichkeit zu gehen wenn wir uns
einschüchtern lassen und Schweigen wird
sich nie etwas ändern sagt sie hier ein
kurzer Auszug aus dem Gespräch
jede ihrer Handlungen in Frankreich
gegen die islamische Republik ist ein
Verbrechen wir werden Ihre Familie in
Iran dafür zur Verantwortung ziehen
nirgendwo auf der Welt werden Familien
für ein Verbrechen in Sippenhaft
genommen aber hier machen wir das so
wenn Sie glauben ich hätte ein
Verbrechen begangen bitten Sie doch
Interpol mich festzunehmen das hat
nichts mit der Polizei zu tun wir werden
ja sehen wie am Ende dafür bezahlt Ende
dieser Woche wird ihre Familie ins
Gefängnis wandern
es ist ein Regime das seine Bürger
bedroht festnimmt foltert tötet sich
gegen dieses Regime aufzulehnen dazu
gehörten Mut
[Musik]
ich habe versucht stark zu sein am Ende
habe ich gesagt ich werde nicht tun was
ihr von mir verlangt ich werde euch
nicht mehr zuhören ich werde mich euren
Drohungen nicht beugen
aber es war sehr sehr hart
[Musik]
seitdem hat sich der Geheimdienst Mann
nicht mehr gemeldet doch jede Minute
kann das Telefon klingeln fürchtet Maxi
ca Marie die Nachricht dass ihre Eltern
für den Protest der Tochter büßen müssen
doch ich habe keine Wahl sagt sie ich
muss reden auch wenn es mir das Herz
bricht
Anfang des Jahres werden zwei weitere
Demonstranten hingerichtet das Regime
weicht keinen Millimeter das zeigt
Wirkung die Proteste lassen nach
[Musik]
im Januar scheint sich das Regime wieder
sicher zu fühlen zum ersten Mal seit
Ausbruch der Proteste bekommen wir die
Genehmigung Teheran zu verlassen unser
Kameramann macht galbi hat seine
Pressekarte zurückbekommen ausländische
Journalisten bekommen wieder
einreisewieser
durch das Albus Gebirge fahren wir
Richtung kaspisches Meer wir wollen über
die schlechte wirtschaftliche Lage
berichten über die US-Sanktionen über
Menschen und Firmen die uns Überleben
kämpfen
auch in cheruz hatte es Proteste gegeben
doch in der Firma nappstahl will niemand
über dieses Thema reden vermutlich gab
es vor unserem Eintreffen einen
anruferministerium hinterher
Geschäftsführer Mann zur Mohammadi führt
uns durch die Fabrik
Ersatzteile für die deutschen Maschinen
gibt es wegen der US-Sanktionen nicht
mehr es ist Arbeiten im ständigen
krisenmodus
auch in Indien haben wir Kunden aber die
kamen und sagten wir können euch kein
Geld mehr überweisen stattdessen können
wir euch schwarzen Stoff für eure
cardoos oder Reis geben
weil Märkte einbrachen erschloss man
sich neue in Asien im Mittleren Osten
und wuchs trotz aller Probleme doch die
Proteste sind Ausdruck einer großen
Unzufriedenheit im Land das belastet
alle Mann zur Mohammadi sehnt sich nach
Normalität
wir wollen dass sich unsere Nation und
unsere Regierung dass ich alle
zusammensetzen Fehler müssen korrigiert
werden und die Probleme zwischen uns
müssen gelöst werden damit der Druck von
uns genommen wird
doch der Druck bleibt der Druck durch
die Sanktionen die hohen Preise es
bleibt die Unzufriedenheit der Menschen
von denen viele aber die Faust in der
Tasche Ballen statt zu protestieren auch
weil das Regime den Druck auf seine
Kritiker aufrecht erhält
nein es waren vor allem Schülerinnen und
Studentinnen die anfangs die Proteste
trugen will sich das Regime nun an ihnen
rächen bereits seit November kommt es zu
mysteriösen giftanschlägen auf
Mädchenschulen zunächst fast unbeachtet
von der Öffentlichkeit laut offiziellen
Zahlen wurden bis März über 5000 Kinder
an 230 Schulen landesweit
Opfer von Angriffen offenbar mit Reizgas
[Musik]
in Teheran treffen wir eine Schülerin
die selbst Opfer eines solchen Anschlags
wurde sie wird von ihrer Mutter
begleitet beide haben Angst wollen nicht
erkannt werden
es war kurz nach der Pause wir hörten
die Klinge und liefen zu unseren
Klassenräumen in der Halle sahen wir
plötzlich Rauch in der Luft es hat sehr
streng gerochen sie bekam Panik fing an
zu schreien und liefen alle raus auf den
hofschmerzen
die meisten Mitschülerinnen schildern
ähnliche Symptome Mariam geht es bald
darauf wieder besser doch ihre Mutter
will wissen was passiert ist
am nächsten Tag bin ich in die Schule
gegangen viele Eltern waren erschienen
doch der Direktor zeigte keinerlei
Reaktion er sagte dass er ein
Schülerstreich gewesen und die Schüler
die das getan hätten hätten sich
hinterher totgelacht das hat er uns
tatsächlich erzählt
wütende Eltern protestieren vor den
Schulen gegen die Untätigkeit der
Behörden und den Versuch die Anschläge
als schülerstreiche abzutun als die
Fälle zum politischen Problem werden
präsentiert das Staatsfernsehen erste
Festnahmen von Tatverdächtigen
die Anschläge aber gehen weiter und so
glauben viele dass das Regime selbst
hinter den Anschlägen stecken könnte
oder dass es religiöse einfacher deckt
auf deren Unterstützung es angewiesen
ist
die Regierung gibt kein gutes Bild ab
ich bin sicher würde es sich um ein
anderes Thema Handeln hätten sie es viel
schneller verfolgt
das Kopftuch richtig tragen als das
Leben von Kindern zu retten
um solche Bilder zu verhindern handelt
das Regime entschlossener als bei der
Aufklärung der Giftanschläge es gilt ein
Symbol seiner Macht zu verteidigen denn
Zwang für Frauen in der Öffentlichkeit
das Kopftuch zu tragen
Kameras sollen helfen bei der Jagd auf
die die sich den Job Vorschriften
wiedersetzen
wir werden moderne erkennungstechnologie
zum Einsatz bringen die Person werden
identifiziert dann werden die Frauen
gewarnt im Wiederholungsfall werden Ihre
Dokumente erfasst und vom Justizsystem
bearbeitet
die moralpolizei ist wieder da verwehrt
bei Verstößen den Zutritt zu U-Bahnhöfen
in den Zügen finden Kontrollen statt
Behörden Geschäfte Banken werden
angewiesen Frauen die gegen die
Vorschriften verstoßen nicht zu bedienen
ein halbes Jahr nach Beginn der Proteste
geht das Regime zur Tagesordnung über
als wäre nichts geschehen
ein Sieg aber ist das nicht die Proteste
finden andere Formen in den sozialen
Medien tauchen solche Tanzvideos auf sie
sagen wir geben nicht auf und zeigen
dass der Abgrund zwischen Staatsmacht
und Volk wieder ein Stück größer
geworden ist
[Applaus]
die nächste masseamini wartet schon um
die Ecke vielleicht in zwei Wochen einem
Monat sechs Monaten
und die Proteste werden dann noch
stärker sein es wird noch gewalttätiger
werden und die Menschen werden dann
nicht mehr so viel Angst vor der
Staatsmacht haben wie es jetzt noch der
Fall ist
obwohl ich weine gebe ich nicht auf und
kämpfe weiter singen sie im kurdischen
sarkast zum Neujahrsfest am Grab von
Gina Massa Amini das Feuer glimmt weiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]